um you are known these days as the
puzzle Rush King in a way you've won a
lot of these puzzle rushes uh what do
you think is the best way to improve
your Tactical skills in
general uh just practice uh yeah just
like with anything else more practice
more repetition is going to be probably
the best thing you can do when I was a
kid uh that's probably like one the main
things I did was just um repeating
tactics are reading through books like
had some of my first books were like 101
checkmates and 101 I don't know tactical
patterns or something um and I would
just like keep doing those so those
patterns kind of got ingrained uh in my
head even though they were like basic
patterns but still was very useful uh as
a starting point did you do them pattern
wise so you started let's say with
double attack pin you said checkmates
did you do it that way or did you mix it
up a little bit so that you keep
developing your your button recognition
uh I think nowadays with most kids
probably train on like websites and
stuff they probably can organize things
the based on the patterns um I think
when I when I was young I was still
reading books so I think the books they
wouldn't necessarily organize Always by
pattern sometimes they would just be
like Checkmate in two and there would be
all sorts of different patterns I don't
think it matters if you if you do them
all like in a row the same pattern it's
also completely fine to do like a
variety of different ones I want to ask
you a little bit um about something that
Bobby fiser said he was focusing a lot
on um he he mentioned that the most
important ability in chess is special
spatial perception uh seeing the
position as it could be what do you
think is more important in chess 9 60s
this is the event you're going to be
competing in uh do you think it's
pattern recognition we already talked
about or is a
visualization yeah that's tricky one cuz
pattern recognition is obviously very
important in chess but obviously 960
kind of disturbs that because you get a
lot of patterns at least in terms of the
peace coordination early on that you
won't get in normal
chess um so the I would say the Str Pawn
structures uh understanding that is like
still very important um but I'm not
really an expert in 960 you know uh if I
I wish I knew like more what was more
important that would help me in this
tournament um as far as spal recognition
I don't think that it necessarily more
important in 916 compared to regular
chess um although I I think that's one
thing I I feel like I don't actually see
things as much as I should like
facially I don't know it's weird like
when I was a kid I was probably like
better at things like blindfold and like
it was easier for me compared to now not
that I can't do that stuff but um you
know I'm I'm getting a little bit too
old so I'm losing my brain cells I don't
believe that but um talking about these
uh recognition and pawn
structure um is there a particular
exercise you think would help uh chess
players to improve their visualization
skills the
most um well calculation um
tactical um position training um or just
calculation would you recommend
blindfold chest I was also going to
mention probably blindfold I mean I
don't know if people do usually do it
specifically to train I feel like it's
kind of just like happens cas
usually um but I think it's also good
training like when I was a a kid um I
remember I used to sometimes play
against my coaches for example Gregory
kaidanov I would just like we would just
play blindfold games with no time limit
so they would sometimes last for a very
long time and go like very deep into the
game and for sure that was you know good
training um for both visualization and
also just getting to play against the
stronger player during this event you're
going to get the positions uh 15 minutes
before you actually have to play how
important are those 15 minutes for your
getting the mindset how you're going to
prepare into the game is it enough is it
not enough I think it's going to be
pretty important or helpful for me
because um you know the 960 at least for
me is pretty pretty unexplored whenever
I played it was just like okay we have a
random position nobody knows anything
about the starting position and we just
go from there but I feel like nowadays
there's probably already some players
who actually know if not the theory in
every position but they know like more
general principles of what might be
different in 960 in the opening compared
to normal chess um which I don't really
have those I don't know what those
special principles are um and in my some
I played a few training games and I
noticed that like in the opening it's so
difficult to actually play accurately
and that's where I was getting outplayed
the most I felt like or I was playing
the worst so for me to have some time
before the game to hopefully be able to
figure out something in the opening
where I get a reasonable Position will
definitely be very helpful for me do you
prefer classical chess or rapidor blades
I feel like I know the answer
but what what do you think think my
answer I think you would say rapid more
rapid than Blitz but I could be wrong
yeah I think those are
more well I wouldn't even necessarily
say more fun obviously like Blitz is fun
um but I think I I mean I enjoy
classical as well it's just for me the
main thing is psychologically when
there's rating it makes a big difference
so like to be honest I feel so much less
pressure here um even if it was normal
chess just because I guess I don't
really care about Rapid or Blitz rating
um and I can just play chess which is
great and I don't really feel like that
extra pressure um I I would say probably
Blitz is the most fun for me and I mean
they're all fun but like rapid I've
probably played the least and I think
objectively I'm probably the worst at it
these days maybe just because I played
the least but it's strange I used to do
do like better in Rapid compared to
classical like when I used to play like
the proest league and things and now
whenever I play online rapid I'm always
doing worse than than before so I don't
know why but this is over the board so
uh I'm really glad to see you don't feel
the pressure and looking forward to see
you play in the competition I have a
final question for you Ray is there a
particular player you're looking forward
to the most to play in this
event um I mean definitely CU far of
like that's amazing that I get a chance
to play against him didn't think that
would ever happen I mean he I remember I
mean he was still playing when I was
growing up I was following all his
tournaments or his matches even against
like
computers um back in like the early
2000s he still had a few matches and uh
yeah then he retired in 2005 so yeah and
he was like my favorite player to follow
so that was really disappointing and um
um I've gotten to meet him before but
you know I never thought I would get
chance to play him so this is really
cool and it's going to be 960 so it'll
be like a new position for both of us so
it's it's really exciting so of course
there are other great players here but
that's definitely the one I'm most
excited about awesome thank you so much
Ray I wish you good luck and looking
forward to seeing your games
[Music]
thanks